[Musique]
à
normal tout le monde je suis un
s'emballe et je dois vous avouer deux
choses je suis belge donc c'est pour ça
que je pars un peu bizarrement et 2 je
suis une breloque
tout a commencé par cette facilité que
j'ai acheté au vietnam et un jour j'ai
vu l'ombre de la tasse sur mon bureau et
j'ai cru apercevoir quelque chose
[Musique]
oh
où
[Rires]
[Musique]
où
un petit et les mots éléphants et pour
moi c'était une étincelle d'inspiration
j'ai vu qu'il ya de la ma vie partout
donc depuis ce moment-là je suis
toujours
[Applaudissements]
je cherche des images dans les ombres et
naturellement l'ombre n'existe pas leçon
[Musique]
sans la lumière
oui j'ai découvert que des créatures
s'est caché dans les ombres de tous les
objets du quotidien
alors j'ai commencé à fouiller dans ma
maison j'ai tout pris même les joueurs
de mes enfants est en fait je suis
devenu un voleur
excusez moi mes enfants chaque objet est
sur terre cachent des images et parfois
même des extraterrestres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'est devenu une sorte de manille
parce que même quand j'ai quand je mange
du bon chocolat belge
je vois des choses
[Musique]
bah
oh
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
ouais dessinée sur scène ça m'a donné
chaud mais heureusement il fait plus
frais à l'ombre
c'est vraiment rafraîchissant
[Musique]
et
ouais c'est cool dans les ombres mais
parfois c'est vraiment très très près si
ça doit vraiment tombé pile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on trouve ça dingue comme ça peut donner
de l'énergie la lumière cce
l'énergie solaire est un site qui appela
musique
surtout quand on est accompagné par
trois buts
bah
fait retarder les ombres c'est un peu
comme regarder les nuages
on y devine des choses qui viennent dans
notre esprit un peu comme dans un test
de rorschach donc forcément parfois je
vois des scènes qui vient de mes films
préférés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
céline de rennes chantons sous la pluie
j'avais presque oublié qu'on était dans
le pays-haut traduit tous les titres ifi
on ne dit pas le tueur ans mais les
dents de la mer
voici les dents j'espère que les autres
ont éclairé votre vie un peu comme elle
à fond pour moi mais maintenant pour
nous il est temps de partir
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]